Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Muchas veces el mayor deseo
de los chicos y las chicas
que tienen alguna discapacidad intelectual
es ser independientes,
ser autónomos, no depender de nadie
a lo largo de su vida.
De hecho, hace muy poco, una joven
que tiene síndrome de Down
me decía que su sueño era viajar sola en subte,
desde estación Congreso hasta Plaza de Mayo,
de una cabecera a la otra, sola.
La tecnología, de a poco,
está permitiendo que estos sueños
se empiecen a hacer realidad.
¿Cómo? Desde la educación, porque
nos permite respetar sus tiempos,
respetar sus necesidades.
Hoy a través de la realidad virtual
y de la inteligencia artificial
estamos siendo capaces de simular
situaciones con los chicos
que ellos después van a vivir.
Desde ir a un médico, o ir al dentista
hasta, incluso, algo más complejo,
por ejemplo, una operación.
De forma que, cuando
efectivamente eso pase,
ellos estén preparados para reaccionar.
Esto es muy importante.
El poder predecir los hechos
es muy importante
no solo para ellos sino también
para todo el entorno.
Es más, ya hay unos primeros prototipos de ropa,
en particular camperas,
que a través de sensores
son capaces de predecir
¿vieron esos berrinches o esos enojos
que a veces tienen los chicos
generalmente que tienen autismo?
Bueno, son capaces de predecirlos
para ayudarlos antes de que suceda.
Las redes sociales;
hoy a través de las redes,
los chicos están saliendo del aislamiento.
Pueden compartir sus experiencias.
Es más, están resultando fundamentales
para la inclusión laboral de
las personas con discapacidad,
que es algo -- dicho sea de paso --
que está creciendo a nivel mundial.
Por último, con la aparición
de las llamadas casas inteligentes,
hoy estamos empezando a pensar
que ellos y ellas, de mayores,
van a empezar a poder vivir solos.
La Internet de las cosas,
esta que escuchamos,
permite diseñar dispositivos
que evitan accidentes,
que facilitan la comunicación,
incluso hacen más fácil la administración
de diferentes aspectos
de un hogar o de una casa.
Actitud de integrar a todas
las personas en una sociedad.
Eso es incluir.
La buena noticia es que a través de la tecnología
lo vamos a ir logrando.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)